you're a lot of things now we love how
you embrace your roots as a daughter of
an evil villain but you're smart brave
cunning and ambitious you're also just a
really great person if you were to
attend Hogwarts we think the Sorting Hat
might have trouble figuring out where to
place you you could easily thrive in any
of the Hogwarts houses but there is one
house that you are probably best suited
for have you ever wondered which
Hogwarts house the vks in their case
would get sorted into keep watching till
the end to find out where we Swart mal
evey it's easy to imagine that ravenclaw
is the house full of nerdy kids but
there's a lot more than being
intelligent than that
Ravenclaw's have a love of learning and
they value wisdom do you this is why
evey it's perfect for ravenclaw
she may be street smart but she's book
smart too she's brilliant at running the
business and she proved that smart girls
can be into girly things like fashion
and fancy castles she would fit in great
with Ravenclaw witches like Cho Chang
and Luna Lovegood Jay we're used to
seeing our heroes get sorted into
Gryffindor this house is number one
trait is bravery Gryffindor's are bold
and believed in doing the right thing
they also don't always think before they
act
Jake is perfect for Gryffindor when he
was a thief he did a lot of daring
things Gryffindor also is the house of
very athletic kids Jay jumps right into
sports when he gets into our Don and
this BK is always quick to jump into
action when difficult situations arise
then hufflepuffs often get a bad rap but
they have some of the most admirable
qualities hufflepuffs are loyal and
never afraid of hard work
they are also dedicated to what is just
and fair King bin is a classic
hufflepuff
he knows that banning the VJs from our
Don is unjust and he knows it won't be
easy to solve but he does it anyway
he puts what is right above everything
else he is also extremely loyal to Mao
and his friends Audrey a lot of people
think that slytherins are all evil but
there are plenty of great wizards that
come from this house slytherins are
defined by being ambitious and cunning
they will use whatever means they can to
achieve their goal this describes Audrey
exactly she is the most ambitious
character in descendants
she wants nothing more than to be a
queen in the first movie she's sneaky
and subversive but in descendents 3 she
proves that she'll do just about
anything to get what she wants looma in
Harry Potter the sorting hat had a hard
time deciding between Gryffindor and
Slytherin for the Boy Who Lived
the Hat would have the same problem with
uma while she is ambitious she also has
an abundance of Gryffindor trays
delivering only lies surprise surprise
she's got nerve and always fights for
what she believes is morally right she's
willing to take big bold steps to help
all the kids on the aisle get a fair
chance we think she and Harry Potter
would get along great Jane the daughter
of the fairy godmother is a perfect
candidate for Hufflepuff hi it's Jane
right I always loved that name Jane she
is loyal to her mom to her school and to
her boyfriend she is always friendly and
super welcoming to the Nuvi Ches in the
first movie she is a hard worker like
the rest of the hufflepuffs she's always
involved in extracurricular activities
that aren't on prep she works hard to
make sure events like cotillion goes
smoothly and she is just so sweet it's
Hufflepuff for her Harry sometimes
slytherins do live up to their
stereotypes and Harry hook is definitely
a sneaky cunning person he has ambition
for days he wants to get to our Don
and he wants a cool girlfriend he is
less bold than uma but still quick to
pick a fight he uses his words as a
weapons and is a total show off that
sure reminds us of several well-known
slytherins from Hogwarts Doug was a
great lady
Ravenclaw's are oft in the top of their
class they love reading and learning
they are also very creative this is my
dog as a perfect Ravenclaw Doug is
really good at school especially science
he helps Evie study and makes her
realize how smart she is he is also in
the band he is also in the band which
shows that he is artistic and he's very
involved in the school he's seen as a
leader on campus in the first movie he
and Doug are definitely the Ravenclaw
power couple Carlos just like his
girlfriend
Carlos is absolutely a Hufflepuff he is
one of the kindest and friendliest
characters in all of descendents he is
extremely loyal first he's loyal to his
mom even though she is horrible to him
but then he is loyal to his real family
the core for he's not afraid of hard
work he spends lots of time working with
computers and he wants to go to
veterinary school that is no easy task
we can't imagine Carlos in any house but
Hufflepuff Mouse it's easy to think that
heroes don't belong in Slytherin but
that's just not the case now isn't evil
but she is cunning she uses sneaky
methods to get what she wants
in the first movie she makes a love
potion and she tells fairy godmother
exactly what she wants to hear in
descendants threes she lies to her
friends so they won't be upset with her
and she lies too much to get her on her
side she's good at heart and she is
definitely a Slytherin and it's time and
that's a wrap which Hogwarts house do
you belong in tell us in the comments
descendants characters sorted into their
Hogwarts houses thanks for watching like
this video and subscribe to the things
for more awesome content we'll see you
next time
[Music]